everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today it's so
easy to be great nowadays because
everybody else's most people are weak I
was so scared of water that I had to
live in the water I had to become one
with the water going to the pool used to
scare me need motivation watch a top-10
believe nation
what's that believe nation it's heaven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something and I want you
to find it embrace it and use it to make
a difference so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who went from
growing up in an abusive household
barely graduating high school and having
serious health issues to completing
seals training and becoming one of the
greatest endurance athletes in the world
he's David Goggins and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success volume to
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one my personal favorite choose to be
great
my favorite game is swim yeah you know
what saying I mean my we had little
athletes in my damn family you know and
I was a kid who kind of got to come up
the of bad genes you know I have all
these little sickly issues all these of
looks like just I was a little sickly
kid it's funny how when people hear my
story now they want to put a title on me
like I'm superhuman yeah like you had
some special and capability and I love
it because basically it makes you feel
better by putting a title on me right
you can do too right
and so bass joints yes choice yeah it's
a horrible choice man
it's a hard choice it's a lot of
suffering involved so for me to get this
dark line through that start line
journey I realize I'm capable mm-hmm so
what happens to this whole process is
the change of the mind mm-hmm it's a
change of the guard mm-hmm
someone once owned my brain I never
owned it
yeah I never had no I had no control you
out your outsourced yes right everybody
had it it was my dad's fault
it was a kids that called me [ __ ]
fault my mom wasn't home fault my
soon-to-be stepdad [ __ ] look kids that
get rid of our bus fault
my life was everybody had a piece of my
brain yeah and through this journey of
suffering and the suffering I put it in
because I started finding myself yeah I
started oh no I'm taking back for me
this part of my brain is mine now I'm so
puzzling back this piece of my brain and
through that I grew confidence in this
process I went from David Goggin I
started forming a guy named Goggins
mm-hmm I had to really invent I realize
I had to reinvent a whole nother human
being right within myself cause it who I
am wasn't gonna make it this is not this
guy is not gonna cut it so I think I did
be a guy who can take any kind of pain
any kind of suffering any kind of
torture mentally physically emotionally
spiritually I had had the people who
visualize everybody that called me
[ __ ] you had to be in a room of people
like this I had to make up these things
in my mind at least I had to overcome
and and I started callous in my mind
you'll do a process in it based out with
working out the start was working out I
started with doing like if it started
raining outside for instance my mind was
said that man I'm gonna run mm-hmm if he
was three o'clock in the morning to
start reading outside my mind said you
gotta go get up and go really you have
to because I was fighting this other
person so you essentially tried to do
everything you didn't want to do that's
all it was
period dot everything I didn't want to
do is what got me to where I'm at today
interest every single thing so where we
find comfort you know that's where I
started getting scared now when I
started saying oh it's raining I'm not
going out there no you cannot say that
you cannot do that you you have got to
do this the other so whatever my brain
thought I did the opposite
mm-hmm wherever the comfort was about
the opposite direction in over a period
of time boy it calluses this mm-hmm out
of your mind you start to really develop
a whole nother being rule number two be
a dreamer I say what if a lot it sounds
corny and it sounds weak but it's true
one of the recruiters said there's not
many black Navy SEALs in fact I was a
thirty six african-american seal in
history is in over sixty years because
the water you know all right I mean
people get mad at me it's true just get
over it and so I was like man what story
would it be if my fat dumb lying to be
friends with people insecure ass can
overcome this and that would if
mentality like that that dreamer
mentality just would always fuel me it
was true and man what if I can be what
if I can be a seal man what if I can go
from wearing a quarter of mile now I run
a tour in five miles what if I can go
but just what if I can go in and what if
how would that feel if I'm graduating
kind of get at that graduation thing I
was talking about 224th like the video I
said then I watched this command officer
stood up and he said to the graduation
guys you're graduating buds like
eighteen of them he said we live in a
society where mediocrities often
rewarded and we don't to say something
about these men to test
mediocrity and I wanted to be a man that
the test mediocrity rule number three
find your why my biggest advice to give
everybody in the world is like I say we
live in an external world everything is
is you got to see it
touch its external if you can for the
rest of your life live inside of
yourself stop listening to people who
are calling you fat gay transsexual
[ __ ] everything that is makes no sense
all these insecure people put their
insecurities on you you gotta flush it
out you got to just be whoever the hell
God or whatever the hell you believe in
if you believe in nothing but yourself I
don't care what it is you're gonna take
everything and throw it away you have to
believe in one thing and that is
yourself and and I'm not saying don't
believe in God or what you believe in
but right now for you to find greatness
in yourself you're not going to find it
by looking in a book or by even hearing
me I may give you the spark but you've
got to go inside yourself to find it and
that means you gotta be quiet shut the
[ __ ] up go in a room stop talking search
your soul search your mind search your
abilities and you'll find it but if
you're not looking for it you won't find
it so you got to go start your journey
and the journey starts with you finding
why the hell am I here
on this planet earth why am I here and
if you don't know that you will live the
rest your life searching always asking
the question why rule number four keep
getting up growing up being the kid I
was I found strengths of different
movies yeah so I come home in one movie
I found a lot of strengths as funny as
it may seem but I visualized this scene
I do it today during the pull up record
if 4030 pull-ups in the last time I did
actually got it to be three times I
played one song for 17 hours pretty much
is from this movie Rocky one round 14
mm-hmm I related to the person in the
movie mm-hmm but just the one scene when
Apollo's beaten Iraqi he falls in the
corner and everybody in rocky in Apollo
arms up happy I got this guy he turns
around not knowing that Rocky's trying
to get up up off the canvas Mickey st.
Mickey's his trainer saying stay down or
everybody's saying you did good you did
good you had 14 rounds with the champ
rockin in here he got up and was dicks
in my mind today seen it right now when
he got up a power starts to turn around
to see the aftermath of what is
destroyed and he did not expect to see
what he saw right and what I see of the
whole movie I see a power crease face
yeah fear of Krypton yes it I said to
myself as a young kid I want to be that
mm-hmm I don't need to win I don't need
trophies
I need people like me I just want what
he has
yeah a fictional character whatever the
hell was I want that and I visualized
that and I want to become the guy who
can get off the canvas and look at
somebody who beat the fish out of him
life was about life right now in life
even life itself pushed her head down
towards a vinyasa yeah this is not going
to stop so that mentality became what I
wanted nice and that's how it started
with that visualization of the canvas
mm-hmm and all I got to do is just keep
getting up rule number five develop a
crazy work ethic that's her negatives
into positives so I would I would take
like who would even think about doing
this so I would sit in my account saying
who at 297 who can't swim that great
who's scared of water
we had the balls kind of balls to man up
quit a job and go and it put everything
on himself so it's how I started talking
to myself and putting myself in a whole
different category and that was fueling
me the next day and I just kept using
that as fuel and fuel no one would do
this no one do this you're the best
around you're the best
never live and I had the guys kept
fueling me with the with the right kind
of message that I needed to hear that
was never
myself through time it became reality to
myself so you start out on the first day
and then you start running again the
second day yeah second day when right
back after again but I started realizing
I can't run that far right so what I did
was I became damn near professional
cyclist with the miles I put it on the
bike so I never whenever I watch TV I
had to be doing something so I was
riding the bike
I ordered a bike a lot to lose the first
initial kind of weight cuz it took my
bones were just hurting so bad my bow is
just broken and I learned to get over
that also and I try to swim a lot I want
a great swimmer but putting fins on kind
of equalize my body I wasn't so negative
buoyant so I started fitting a whole
bunch and I spent hours in the pool
hours in the pool trying to get more and
more comfortable not because I was going
underwater I was so scared of the water
that I had to live in the water I had to
become one with the water so going to
the pool used to scare me so I went to
pool an awful awful lot and then the
bike got easier I was able to run more I
went from like one mile well Maya was a
great accomplishment 2 miles and then
from 2 to 3 was a bigger then I went
from 3 to 6 and then like they have a
warning order that they get people to
get ready for butts and the whole thing
was running 6 miles 5 days a week and
that was my goal and so I just kept I
failed I go back to scratch I used some
positive motivation I have like one day
when I back defeated but I started
realizing this a part of the process
this a part of the journey I had to
realize this is part of my process
versus just saying like I used to
I'm just not good enough if I'm not good
enough we always say that I'm it's not
good enough and then we try something
else I'm gonna make myself good enough
and that became my mentality I'm gonna
make myself good enough and so I
misunderstood a lot but that's that's
all it came down to I made myself good
enough and the days I couldn't run that
far the next week I would do two a days
so on the running if I ran a quarter a
mile I wait a couple hours it haunt me
bother me I try to run a half mile next
time same day
you can do more than this if I had to
walk had to walk it just became just a
process of grinding and grinding and
grinding is not even a good word for it
it's not even a good word for it and
just just going further and further and
then when I got through running I go to
the bike I go to the pool if I got tired
somewhere my legs are tired I go to the
gym and I develop this crazy workout
where I was doing volume like two-three
hundred reps of like very lightweight
people are saying how you know how come
you'll have any like loose skin my
workout routine in the gym became sick
it became sick I was just doing two
300-400 reps on my chest just like for
one simple exercise the best press and
our racket get back on it just rep it
out trying to burn as many calories I
can't build that muscle mass and I just
became just became possessed with it
rule number six attack he once said that
if you were growing up in this
generation that you would have a field
day because you would take their souls
what did you mean by that the younger
generation quits not everybody so I got
it I got put that he would get their
butt hurt so not everybody most of this
generation quits the second they get
talked to you did this wrong you did
this wrong or they get yelled at it's so
easy to be great nowadays because
everybody else is most people are weak
this this is a softened generation so if
you have any mental toughness any of any
ability be of any fraction of
self-discipline the ability to not want
to do it but still do it people have a
hard thing understand I hate to run and
what makes me so crazy it doesn't need
more people why did you run if you hate
it what are you talking about I don't
want to take showers and eat either I
hate that too that the whole that's a
life man
that and it wasn't until I changed that
mentality that I became somebody I hate
it going to school so guess what I was
dumbest that's what will one plus one is
two but if you can get through to doing
things that you hate to do on the other
side is greatness that's what people are
saying by me running I encounter sin my
mind I'm not training for a race I'm
training for life
I'm training for the time when I get
that two o'clock in the morning call
that my mom is dead or something happens
tragic in life I don't fall apart I'm
training my mind and my body my spirit
so it's all one so I can handle what
life is gonna throw at me because the
life I've lived it throws a whole bunch
at you and if you're not physically
immensely prepared for that you're just
gonna crumble and you're good for nobody
talk to me about what it takes to be on
one side of a door in Iraq or anywhere
knowing on the other side of the door
people who are not afraid of you they're
ready for you to come in and you still
have and they have guns and you still
have to breach that door that's a great
question it that's a very scary
situation when you are on one side of
the door and your mind is racing because
on the other side of that door it could
be no one it could be four guys with
four ak-47s that that door you're about
to open can be booby-trapped so once you
open it boom your legs are gone
so there's a thousand things you think
about when you're the first guy second
guy third guy getting ready going to
room and flood it and that's what I talk
about the warrior mentality and that's
why so many people are lost when I start
talking you have the right you're lucky
that you don't have to think like
warriors think you're very privileged I
chose this world to be a warrior and I
don't and I would choose it again if I
came back to this world but the
mentality of a warrior is very different
than normal mentality you must be that
person on that door Oh get ready to open
it thinking to yourself if I die so be
it the only way you can go in that door
is know there's a great chance you're
gonna die it's like being a seal you
train with live ammo you jump on an
airplane every
everything you do you could die so to be
a warrior
why people don't understand me I'm glad
understand me Merry Christmas good on
you because being a warrior takes a
whole different mindset a whole
different mindset to know that there's a
great chance I may not be didn't look
like I was in for 21 years I'm lucky I'm
very lucky that I'm alive able to talk
to you able to still run but when you
sign up with a downline to be a set like
a seal your mentality changes I may not
live
you got except that and that's the
mentality you have and that's what makes
you a warrior if you're scared to die
you're a bad warrior I hate it jumping
out of airplanes I hated shooting guns I
hate it the job as a Navy SEAL
but I did it because I wanted to change
myself everything I do I'm not really
comfortable doing but if you choose to
go that route to go be a Navy SEAL you
might as well go be the hardest in the
world because if you're choosing to do
something you have two routes you can go
there and be a little a little weak
person and get through barely and that's
your reputation or you can go through
the hardest guy you can possibly be a
nice reputation so my whole thing is if
you're gonna choose to open that door in
Iraq or Afghanistan
open them and go in hard because they're
gonna remember you by slowly opening and
peeking in so if you're gonna open it
and you made the mind open it don't
crack it open open the door go in that's
with life if you choose to do if you
choose to do something attack it because
they're gonna remember you as not
attacking it so I want to be remembered
you can hate me but one thing you can't
say about me I didn't attack it so
that's the mentality have if you're
gonna do something you might as well
attack it because you do it anyway right
do use that in civilian life like do you
still employ though I'm in attack it I'm
gonna take their souls like how does
that play out in a non-combat zone
it still works for me in in life as far
as attacking things because uh no matter
what I want to
no matter what Avenue I choose I want to
be the very best and the very best may
not be I'm number one the very best is
did I leave everything inside of me out
there so attacking it's not like I want
to win this or win that or be the best
the best is I'm running against myself
and everything I do and and that's and
that's what I attacked I attacked myself
I'm always questioning myself I'm always
hoarding myself accountable rule number
seven take accountability as a leader
the one thing I did horribly wrong on my
second platoon I actually started
developing an attitude towards people
who didn't at Pt heart mm-hmm who didn't
get after who worked I know I took it
all the way to the limit and so I should
have been a better leader by knowing
okay not everyone wants to be David
Goggins now never wants to go for a
hundred miles everybody everyone's got
the skill says yeah right you know maybe
you know want to go to the gym whatever
the gym is fine but it was just a
different standard so I couldn't take
away my standard for the whole about the
group interesting I looked at people you
man
you know you yeah you ain't rank if
Norfolk you saw my mentality I wasn't a
good leader and I look back on that now
trust me a lot of people could other
things differently I'm taking account of
duty for I could've done different I
looked at that much so my mentality from
a weak kid became super hard like beyond
hard next-level hard and um but that's
what I was getting myself into
as a leader I should have stepped back
and I say these are your expectations
David Goggins right what are we here to
accomplishment it's important to lead by
example and I say lead by example if
you're the leader is the loneliest job
on the planet and if you do it you have
to be up early you leave late you got do
the sucky jobs at least that's how I
look at it you got to be the man that is
always the person who's being held
accountable to the highest standards
mm-hmm and I expecting your people do
anything that you're not gonna do 20
times more than they are even with even
with you're the leader
mm-hmm and and I mean it's all about
accountability for yourself in a
leadership role it's not about being
pissed because
people aren't doing what you're doing
mm-hmm they're about different skill
sets rule number eight break the limits
[Music]
when you think that you are done you
only forty percent into what your body
is capable of doing and that's just a
limit there that we pour ourselves
[Music]
got our leader of the 150-mile coming in
[Applause]
you never get really know how I feel I
never really tell you the truth I'm
always gonna feel good I want to feel
and show you no weakness
congratulations buddy thanks a lot man
what a fifty-mile champion first place
new course record way to go gradually
I'm never happy and satisfied with one
thing I do is always a continuous
journey in all my races there's never in
it's kind of fallen in together it's
like one big journey that that won't
inside I rule number nine do yoga do you
ever do yoga all the time man all the
time and I if I were to tell somebody
one thing right now man that's so as
muscle and getting that hip flexor
opened up because we're all stressed to
figure out it was it's almost worse than
others it changed my life I'm one of
those drawn on too much about yoga I'm
like one of those vegans it's like you
got to do it man right I get it knowing
like a born-again Christian or something
it's like I'm getting that way now man
no way now for anybody does anything
hard like you know if you do anything
like with weight lifting types or
martial arts types where it's just
everything's explosion its lifting it's
heavy
push push push right yoga just will
balance your out yeah well yeah really
well man and there's all these people
that resist it like there was some
article recently that it was something
along the lines of hot yoga is just
trendy nonsense I've read that and then
even in the article it talked about that
there might be some benefits in terms of
like the strengthening your arteries and
they didn't even mention heat shock
proteins there's a study going on right
now I believe it's at Harvard right one
of my friends was telling me about it
where they're they're trying to find the
benefits of 90 minute hot yoga classes
because they think it might mirror the
observed benefits of sauna which they
already know for a fact has big benefits
because of your body producing heat
shock proteins to deal with the heat
right that's why put that sauna in here
man I go enough or all the time but no
one can tell me he doesn't work it's big
it's proof positive he changed my life
that it wasn't a medication or this or a
dress it was stretching yeah it was yoga
stretching all that stuff combined
changed it and
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is embrace the suck
so when things hit you in life that
you're afraid of or you're not good at
the first thing you girls say to
yourself is why am I here anyway this
isn't for me the water is too cold the
sun's too hot I'm getting up too early
why am i doing this to myself that's
what the normal mind says I had to start
training my mind to think about how can
I get through this not giving myself a
way out never give myself creating a
wall around all the ways out in my mind
and a slowly starts to build this wall
so my mind knew this is not gonna give
himself a way out of here
in my first home we had a huge setback I
was broken my legs were broken I had
double pneumonia I got rolled back to
day one week one of Navy SEAL training I
got through that second hell week during
that second hell week I actually broke
my knee I continued to limp around for a
couple weeks I couldn't make it anymore
got rolled back to day one week one I'll
never forget standing there in front of
captain Bowen he was a co in charge of
Navy SEAL training at the time and he
had no mercy on anybody if he believed
in managing your expectations I wouldn't
be here today he challenged me again I
was challenged my whole life not by the
mindset of managing expectations by
exceeding expectations not by managing
them I'm standing there with crutches
I'm sitting in his office he looks at me
he goes jogging this year last time
we're gonna push you through Navy SEAL
training this would be your third hell
week in one year
we're not gonna put you through a 40 so
this is your last time I'm sitting
thinking how am I gonna get through this
I'm badly jacked up my legs are broken
my knee is messed up and he goes 'i have
a couple of months to get better a
couple of months isn't gonna do it I
won't get healed up in a couple of
months but I realized I'm going to get
through this I'm gonna find a way to get
through it cuz why I put barriers in my
mind so my throat hell week I went in
there with pretty much I would put a
black sock on first I would get duct
tape and I duct-taped my ankles all the
way up to my calf every single morning
then I put another black sock over it
and what that did that prevented me from
moving my ankle so I didn't really I
wasn't flexing my shin as much now I
started running with just my hip flexors
then this hell week it was a bad Hilary
and a guy died on Thursday morning of
hell week I went on to become a Navy
SEAL greatness is not something that you
meet once it's something that should
meet thousands of times in your life and
you don't reach it if you're not
constantly in constant pursuit of
greatness so if my mom would say right
now I'm great I just lost we're gonna
grow we're not going to triple down on
our strengths we're not gonna do that
crap we're going to work on our
weaknesses so we grow we need friction
to do that without friction there's no
growth without friction this confusion
confusion is David gagas how did you
become who you are today I put a bunch
of friction in my life and I grew that's
how I did it you ought to get really
tough it's a lifestyle
it's Ted hitting that snooze button in
the morning and not making your bed and
not cleaning your house you don't get
this news button you get up you don't
want to go run you go run then we're
gonna swim you go swim you wanna make
your bed you make your bed you know
where to clean your house to clean your
house you don't we're a study study
that's time you start to callus your
mind so that became my life if you say
you're gonna wake up at 4 o'clock in the
morning to go run wake up at 4 o'clock
enough it's going to suck it's not gonna
be fun do something that sucks every
single day of your life that's how you
grow embrace the suck
I've got a really special bonus David
Goggins clip on how to stop feeling
sorry for yourself that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question
today I want to know which message
resonated more with you break the limits
or find your why let me know in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
I was in Spanish class obviously open
the notebook up he said [ __ ] we're
going to kill you
had a drawing of me and actually talk to
the principal because I'm in the process
of writing my book right now his name is
Kurt Freeman Neil yeah I talked to me
today's ago no kidding he said I
remember like like it was yesterday
so I left my class just didn't tell a
teacher we write to his office and
showed him it and he said and I've
learned a good speller at all obviously
I got a topic and they spelled Niger
Niger I know I spoiled Niger you know
I'm saying they they spelled Niger Niger
so he looked at me and said they're
ignorant and that was the best advice
you can give me my mom's working three
jobs I was a latchkey kid I was I was on
my own I did my own thing man
I missed almost all my junior year of
high school never to school just did my
own thing
and um that was a turning point when I
really realized I was on my own I mean
it just kind of hit me like the best
advice you can give me is just build
Niger Niger mm-hmm and pretty much you
know I think he called my mom up and I
went back to class and I realized that
life isn't fair it's not fair and you
better figure out some tools and some
ways to stop feeling sorry for yourself
because no one is coming to rescue you
no one feels sorry for you right and it
did a day no one really cared about me
that's how it felt that was the reality
of it if you tell yourself a story long
enough you start to believe it won't you
believe you act like I have Tulsa what a
wail out of handcuffed lightning though
Thunder in jail now you know I'm bad all
the last week I murdered a rock into the
stone hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I
make medicine sick the fundamental key
to success is it can take between
eighteen and two hundred and fifty four
days of taking action for a new habit to
stick I've created a new course called
250 for confidence or every single day
for 254 days I will be sending you a
video between 30 seconds and 5 minutes
long that you start your morning with
around making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access